je sais un petit peu de place pour la
personne voilà voilà comme ça il ne me
dit rien je peux me servir de tout ça ou
pas vous pouvez tout faire ici on ici
maintenant c'est votre émission moi je
me casse voilà est on plus on parle de
vous 1 ça m'arrange pas me connaissez
les questions qui attire bien sûr je
suis un grand fan
mon client est vrai qu est-ce qui fait
ben j'ai récupéré des images un peu
partout à paris
je vais révéler le vrai visage des
camarades à des ex camarades mais moi je
le connais c'est vraiment c'est dire à
moore va regarder aller une question
tout de suite bonjour je m'appelle
dominique je trouve que cyril hanouna à
la grâce d'un aigle royal
donc je voulais savoir quel est son
secret pour être aussi majestueux
dominique est douce leed je comprends
votre question dominique mais je vais
avoir du mal à y répondre car personne
ne connaît vraiment le secret de cyril
pour le percer il ferait s'approcher du
du maître mais c'est impossible car vous
savez ce qui se passe quand on
s'approche trop près du soleil mais je
vais faire ce que je peux alors sait
déjà c'est un contexte unique un unique
avec son public générosité il
s'intéresse vraiment aux gens et pose
les bonnes questions
là c'était entre le direct est le
problème de jeudi dernier ça valait bébé
tu restes sur le prime avec ton zizi ou
sentons zizi
[Rires]
mais oui mais c'est important car vous
savez peut-être pas mais quand vous
venez dans le public on vous demande de
laisser votre vestiaire votre talent et
votre visite
c'est comme ça serris et c'est un vrai
leader
on est tous témoins une chose
essentielle pour lui c'est que ces
chroniqueurs soit toujours à son écoute
nous savons tous donc quand il nous
parle nous lui répondons toujours comme
ici valérie bénaïm à la fin d'une
émission à
[Applaudissements]
non
ça c'est génial parce qu'elle t'a fait
le petit regard des sons c'est bon prix
mais elle s'est tout b line c'est comme
ça qu'à me lâcher
une des grandes forces de cyril
également c'est la confiance qu'il a en
lui en son physique
d'ailleurs il s'en cache pas à l'antenne
écoutez le c'est l'instrument brésilien
une cote de fou la majoration
c'est vrai je suis sûr qu'au brésil chez
harry 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
j'adore ce qu'ils ont fait ici là une
voie sans rimes la durée qu'on balade
dans les bois d'autres avenues dans les
bois de travaux nécessaires au chili
fait la voix de bernard lavilliers
oui c'est vrai dans les favelas plutôt
les femmes je vais vous livrer un autre
secret dans l'équipe chacun ses rituels
pour se préparer
par exemple avant de rentrer sur le
plateau pour se donner du courage cyril
chauffe savoir des ducs irrite a failli
dire j'ai l'accord il fait des choses
bizarres cooptation c'est pas moi
pygmées un moment mais ça d'autres
choses savoie en poussant un petit cri
puis il invoque l'esprit de l'oiseau qui
le représente le mieux à savoir l'aigle
royal 6 nabila ben nabila exactement le
même rituel
sauf qu'elle s'est pas dans l'est qui se
reconnaît les particules
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas fait exprès à un code avec mon
mec en fait d'accord c'est une buse
à quand vous êtes content il n'aura le
fait pareil les 10 des petits pulls
raison il adore les bras et votent les
petits qu avant l'émission c'est pas
pourquoi viendront pas ce qu'elle a dit
est une buse quand elle est contente
avec 100 mais qu'apparemment elle sort
avec un gardien de zoo je suis comme ça
je répète une butte de buch autre règle
d'or sert il il faut l'écouter car il
est brillant si je vous ai bryant n'est
pas de votre faute
et entre deux bêtises et il peut nous
dire un truc qui va révolutionner le
monde de la télé donc tout le monde lui
répond sérieusement au cas où
comme ce techniciens sont sur la droite
écoutez le bien on sent qu'ils marchent
sur des oeufs avec cyril droit tu ne
mettait pas dans mon cul
[Applaudissements]
est ce que le mec qui va pas avec ça va
pas trop marché je savais que c'était ce
qu'il voulait dire en public et sa
technique parce que ça va être étouffée
du coup on s'est compliqué contredire un
génie quand un micro ça se met dans le
cul et cyril est aussi très généreux
avec les gens qu'il aime comme comme
mokhtar mokhtar zazou donc dès qu'il
peut il lui fait des cadeaux
regardez bien jusqu'au bout ça s'arrête
bientôt pour toi c'est pas si ça va
rentrer en poussant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
supra mur ne m'en voudrez pas plu je me
serais battu à mort
c'est le délire maintenant je suis là
quand tu t'occupes réduisent seraient
les prochaines 4/3
bon alors est en fait tu t'attaques à
mokhtar pourquoi parce qu'il est frêle
et sans défense c'est minable
c'est vrai que c'est minable alors série
n'est pas d'être à part et pour bien
apprécier il faut connaître son langage
et comprendre ses compliments
regardez la différence de réaction entre
quelqu'un qui a l'habitude
gilles verdez est quelqu'un qui n'a pas
l'habitude nabila merci combien c'est
pas pour dire jean luc je trouve cette
formidable cette chronique mais tu
décris c'est une émission que tous les
français il adore et en gros tu le dit
avant que ça tourne il ya un gars il est
là là chaque le zizi le cul c'est que ça
alors pas du tout mais c'est pas ça
c'est aussi il prend que le pire non
gestion gcrai main il ya pire non
mesdames il est choqué j tu lui dis
belge at il est content il est bizarre
il est bizarre il est très étrange il ya
deux semaines rappelez vous il avait été
victime d'un plan ignoble fomenté par
cyril et jean-michel rappelez vous c'est
quoi perdre n est pas ce que vous voulez
pas parler avec ce style dans la
vénitienne
regardez on va voir ce que ça va faire
garder à lédenon même prenez le bien
avait levé à l'égout la vengeance est un
plat qui se mange pas non non
[Musique]
et pour ta tête et on a loupé le moment
où thierry lice le met dans le club
[Rires]
qu'est ce que j'entends qu'est-ce que je
encore temps c'est déjà assez
surréaliste d'avoir ce genre de
séquences dans une émission médias mais
savez vous pourquoi elle est quand même
rester chic quéven mais jean-luc eh bien
non c'est parce que la production
veiller au grain et c'est jean michel
qui nous l'expliquent
[Musique]
dans les mémoires
un an
m
voilà attendez on va faire un petit
point là avant que tout le monde suit
bien la problématique de la situation
regardez donc il ya jean michel stylo
dans le derrière la question qui pose
c'est aurait aimé ou pas ce que c'est
vrai que c'est une question qu'on peut
se poser à la surprise générale gilles a
répondu plus je pense que c'est l humour
j'espère que c'est de l'humour en tout
cas thierry moreau a pris ça au premier
degré ce qui a donné lieu à une des
conversations les plus improbables que
j'ai entendu dans cette émission avec en
prime une leçon de vie donnée par jean
michel à son camarade
ah c'est pour vous allez c'est pas
[Musique]
s'aimer
de ligue les bras
[Musique]
mae
tu
un pouce on peut voir la gêne ans des
deux femmes à côté elles sont gênantes à
côté de son nez dans la merde alors
c'est fou ça va c'est une belle leçon de
vie sains
j'essaye ce que j'aime c'est à la fin
c'est bah ouais mon gars c'est comme ça
jean gabin c'est comme normal tu joues
bien des cubes mais le mec ne doute de
rien et pourtant il devrait faire preuve
d'un peu plus d'humilité parce que mardi
un passage de l'émission a beaucoup
interpellé nos téléspectateurs tout de
suite une petite piqûre de rappel a
alors je vais vous dire qu'il vous a
balancé en bastonnant du tout c'est qui
c'est lui là depuis dix ans je vous
avais dont il s'appelle bien balancé qui
a balancé mais lui dit mais il s'appelle
michel oui nabila ne connaît pas jean
michel maire
comme j'aimerais être dans ce même cas
beaucoup de gens ont réagi sur les
réseaux sociaux en disant que c'était
anormal de ne pas s'intéresser à ses
collègues de travail de deux pas de
capable de citer leurs noms ils ont
raison bon je voulais vous montrer un
extrait juste avant le prime touche pas
mon public au moment où on se demandait
qui allait faire partie ou pas de
l'émission
et comme là
pas mais il ya du bien et nos et
et à gilles essai
fait
[Musique]
saliao
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais ça va alors vous sortez dabila
vous sortez pas son prénom voulant pas
été vexé mais moi je n'ai pas à comparer
un jeu ses papiers babouche revenant
parce que si tu avais dit rocco siffredi
lors été flatté comment sais tu
commences à être vexé dans cette
émission je n'allais pas faire long feu
il énerve tout le monde c'est pas un
problème mais cela m'a sans doute
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
tu fais un truc des cabanes de la
tension dans l'émission ce constat très
gênant chez moi je voulais te le dire tu
te met à danser doucement c'est pour
demander une solution
ces dispositions voilà bah oui demandé
cette dure deux ans voilà elle va se
calmer un petit peu oublié cet épisode
heureusement les autres membres de
l'émission se connaissent mieux sont
plus complices par exemple isabelle
d'accord il va pas bien elle sait
qu'elle peut toujours trouver dure qu
[Rires]
elle sait qu'elle peut aller chez
conforama
ça joue bien non j'ai buggé simplement
c'est que les comptes auprès de qui moi
oui de syrie série qui est toujours à
son écoute
ah oui je les adore
[Musique]
l'eau
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
baby qu'elle n'allait pas j'ai même pas
vu c'est l'attaqué et bien c'est qu'elle
insiste pas alors la série moment de
solitude le plus beau des trois
dernières semaines
c'est cette belle connivence qu'on a
senti entre jijel soares et isabelle
mergault
moi ça fait mon bonheur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et l'autre quand ça concerne les jantes
elle rigole je vais t'attraper lanta
l'émission jusqu'à il ya deux semaines
j'avais montré que jean-michel qui
critiquent toujours nicolas canteloup
avait si l'ancien nouveau concept la
micro imitation à l'âge je vous rappelle
ce qu'est enora malagré
c'est bien ça aurait bien bien pour la
venue d'isabelle mergault jean-michel
ajouté une deuxième femme à son
répertoire
là il tente limitation de voix vous
allez voir c'est très rapide et surtout
c'est très gênant il appelle moi j'adore
votre voix
j'adore voter je vous aime bien mais je
vous jure que c'est vrai il avait il
avait dit la logique finalement
un des plaisirs de syrie essaie de faire
danser jean-michel avec nos invités
féminine là on en a parlé tout à l'heure
c'était et cristina cordula ah oui
juste à jean michel maire ça vous a plu
cd génial jean-luc vu ses difficultés à
bouger je pense que c'est clair il a
bandé c'est ce que vous avez vu à lampes
led la suite ça n'a pas été vu ses
difficultés bouger je pense que c'est
clair il a bandé
oui
elle dit il est comme ça et on venu en
aventurière dans cette émission un on en
est où là j'ai encore du temps où sert à
quoi vous avez deux minutes
ah bah alors on est on est on n'est pas
bien on va aller vers la fin on va les
surveiller les deux derniers magnéto
alors on va avancer on va on avance on
avance
c'est une évidence oui voilà non je
voulais parler de isabelle morini bosc
qui dansent et beaucoup de gens me
disent que isabelle fait n'importe quoi
et bat pas du tout en fait c'est pas du
tout improvisé vous allez voir là il va
danser sur bella à un moment elle va se
rendre compte qu'elle est fausse va
réfléchir vous allez voir quand les
trouve les bons mouvements
ça change tout à la chorégraphie
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
oui comme tata yoyo il ya dans sa tête
il ya des tas d'oiseaux oui mais bon une
femme aussi créative mais a été bien un
bel hommage donc pour vous un nouveau
numéro de danse avec isabelle morini
bosc
ils peuvent toujours bossé à des fins
ils n'atteindront jamais ce niveau
achats d'or
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
c'est pas assez fort pour moi
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jugez plutôt
merci
[Applaudissements]